Ahzubillahi mina shaytanur regime Bismillahir Rahmanir Raheem Alhamdulillahi khalikal wujoodi minal 'adam waja'il nuri mina zulam wa mukrijis sabri minal 'alam wa mulkit tawbati 'alan 'adam pa nashkuruhu alal masa'ibi ka nashkuruhu alal ni'am wa nusalli ala rasool hilakram wulissharaf al-asham wa nooril 'atam wal kitab al-mahkam
Wa kamalin nabiyina wal khatam Sayyadi waladi 'adam aladi basharabihi aisabnumariyam Wada'alibiya satihi Ibrahimu alaihis salam Hina kaana yarfa'u ka waida baitillahil muharram Fasallallahu alaihi wa alaihi wa salam wa ala adba'il khairil ummam aladi barakallahu bihim ka fatanas alaaraba minhum wal ajam
Wa salallahu ala ameerul momineen alanza'il bateen maqa ibil ghurul mahajjaleen Ghalib ala kulli ghalib matloobi kulla kaalib Mawlana ali ibn Abi kaalib Alhamdulillah, al-Lazi anzala ala 'Abduhil kitab, walam yaja Allahu aywaja.
Walhamdulillah, al-Lazi lam ya takhiz waladan, walan ya kun lahu sharikun fil mulk, walam ya kun lahu wal yum minazullay wa kabbir hutalbira
Wa alhamdulillah al-ladeenahmaduhu wa nastaainuhu wa nastaahtharuhu wa nu'minubhi wa na tawakkalu 'alai Wa na udubillahi min shururi anfusina wa min sayyi'ati 'amalina Man yahdihillahu falamudillah wa man yudlilhu falahaadi Allah Wa nashadu Allaha ilaha illa Allah Wahdahula sharikalah Wa nashadu Anna Muhammadan Abdullahi wa rasulih
Arsalahullahu ta'ala bilhudawadeen al-haq liyuzhirahu ala deenu kulli wa kafa billahi shaheedah Fasallahu alayhim wa 'ala alayhim wasalim hum tasliman kasiran kasira Allahum mala 'ilmalana illa ma alamtana inna ka'antala 'alimul Hakeem Allahumma alimna bima yanfa'ana wa yanfa'ana bima alamtana Allahumma inna na uzubika mina 'ilmin la yanfaa wa min qalbin la yaksha
Wa min aainin la tadmaa wa min nafsin la tashpaa Fa'am ma baadiyakulu subhana wa taalasi kitabihil kareem bada nakula audubillahi minis shaytan ar-rajim bismillahir rahmanir raheem Rabbish rahli sadri wa yasidli amri wahlu laqdatam millisani yaf tahu kawli Allahum masabitna aimdal maawtibila ilaha illa Allahum wa jaallaminalladina amanu waamilu salihat wa tawa saaw bilhaq wa tawa saabr
Once again, Assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
You know, we're talking at the direction in which I'm taking these discussions is towards the topic of ilah.
But as I said that you cannot really understand ilah.
In order to truly understand and appreciate the meaning of the word ilah, you need to understand what love means, especially in the Islamic sense, in the Quranic sense, and
You cannot understand love, you cannot fall in love with someone without being friends.
So friendship is what we covered in the previous session, and we looked at the various qualities that make up a perfect friend.
Right, so there is the quality of wali, protection, being a protective friend, a siddiq, a sincere and true friend, a sahib, which is a companion, a walija, a trustworthy,
Bitana, which is a confidant, Khalil, an intimate friend, there was Rafiq, a comforting friend, Qareen, which was a compatible friend.
So we looked at all these different traits, and like I said, think of it like a rainbow, that all of these traits come together in a perfect friend.
A perfect friend from a Quranic standpoint is not one of these things, it is a combination of all of these traits.
But when it comes to love, the Arabs have what they call Maraat e Bulshabd, which is the stages of love.
So, what they say is that love increases in 10 stages.
And basically, it starts at level 1, then goes on to level 2, level 3.
They pretty much describe love like a fever, so it just keeps getting
warmer and warmer So they have they describe love in ten stages, which they call Maratha Bulhog and these are the ten levels of love And now generally you can look at this these stages in the worldly sense It's definitely applicable in the worldly sense at least to a certain level but the idea and the goal of this discussion is You know, it's more divine love rather
seeing Allah as the beloved so um you know with that I'll I'll I'll begin this topic so Bismillah the first level of love is what they call Alaqa okay um and what Alaqa is it's um right the connection of the heart with the beloved so Alaqa is basically
a connection.
Now in Arabic Allaqa is a hanger you know what you use to hang your clothes on.
Now a hanger has a hook and you know by definition a hanger means something to hang upon so that's how they get this word Allaqa which is basically you know a connection of the heart.
So the heart gets connected it gets hooked it gets attached to the beloved this is the first stage.
so in our terms this is what we call attachment or you know generally we say what we call a crush in our terms right that's Halaqa so when you're at this first stage that's when you say like you know I've got a crush on this person or that person or I'm attached to this person or that person so that is basically Halaqa and this type of attachment could
either mean something or it could be very temporary it could just be like an instant you know attachment and attraction and then it's over or you know it could progress but basically that hook, that first connection is what they call Alaka.
The second level is Irada which is willful love.
This is where you actually
begin looking for the beloved.
So it's turidhuhu, you know, you make an effort to seek out the beloved.
And at this stage, the lover is called a murid because he sets out with a goal or a purpose to find the beloved.
You see?
The first level was, you know, a simple connection of the heart, right?
But at this stage, there is a pursuit
of what the heart desires with a particular intention, with an eradha.
So, it's basically considered the beginning of the journey, right?
So, that's the next stage.
Eradha is the stage where you begin to desire the company of the beloved and it's not just an attraction, you actually want to meet.
The beloved.
So, there's alaqa, there's eradha.
The third one is what they call Sababa.
Now, this Sababa, it comes from an Arabic expression which is Sabalma.
The Arabs use this term to describe a waterfall.
That's what Sabalma is, right?
It's a waterfall.
So, we can think of this stage, this third stage in English as falling in love.
Right?
So, Sababa is the stage where you begin to feel like you're falling in love.
It's where you
begin to lose control and that's the insibaab so Sababa is sort of you know you begin to lose control and you actually know that you are falling in love with this person and you start feeling all weird inside okay so alright so that's the third state Sababa right falling in love then you have Gharam.
Which is a it is a sort of mulazima you know like the punishment in the Hellfire that's you know walladina ya kuluna rabbana asrif anna aga ba jahannam inna aga bahat kaana gharaama so indeed the punishment in the Hellfire is never going to end right the punishment doesn't stop.
There so the idea of gharaam is sort of la yan fakku it's sort of it's never ending.
So this Gharam is the state where you know the Arabs they refer to it as.
Like mughrim bihi which means that they just want to be with the beloved right so it's a very strong desire to just be with the beloved all the time and distance actually becomes painful at this stage.
So Gharam is where it's like an obsession, it's a non-stop obsession about the beloved.
You just can't stop thinking about the person.
You know, they say a sign of people at this stage, at this fourth stage is when you find them constantly like staring at the beloved's pictures.
Have you ever
seen that like you know where people just constantly stare at the beloved's picture or they keep going back and reading their letters over and over and the same e-mail the same text messages over and over and over again right that's Gharam because what it does is it gives them a sense of being close to the beloved and it reduces the pain of the distance from them so you know this is the state of Gharam when when this person just
The only way he feels comfort is when he actually.
Gets some sort of that physical connection with the, you know, either through a picture, letters, whatever, right?
But it's a non-stop feeling of obsession.
So that's the fourth state.
So you can see how it increments, right?
It starts with the connection, then there is irada, there is the intent of pursuit joins that connection.
Then there is the Baba where you know it begins to feel like they realize that they're falling in love and then it's a Gharam where this obsession begins to develop.
So that's the fourth one.
The fifth one is what they call wood.
Wood, right?
Waw dal wood.
And the lover is called Al-Wudood.
The word Wud, it means pure love, right?
Wud is, it's Safwatul Muhabba, it's the purity of love.
It is love that is now pure from the inclinations of the self.
A love that is pure from the inclinations of the self.
You know in these previous states where you had
you know, Alaqa, Sababa, Gharam, all of these states, there's always still some nafs involved.
There was still some selfish reasons for loving the beloved, for wanting to see them, for desiring them, for thinking about them.
There's nafs involved.
In these previous stages, it's really more about you than it is about the beloved.
But when you move into the stage of Wud, it starts becoming pure.
It starts becoming selfless.
Right?
So, this is why the Messenger of Allah , he said, there's a Hadith in which he said, what was it?
He said, ...
Marry a fertile woman who is wudud.
You know, marry a woman who has this type of pure love.
A woman whose love is not selfish.
And obviously in Arabic, there is always, you know, mafroom al mukhalifa, which means that the opposite is also true, that a woman should also look for a husband with that quality.
So Al-Wadood is this pure kind of love, in which there is no inclination of the self.
Now, interestingly, if you know, some of you might have realized this, that this is also one of the names of Allah , right?
He is Al-Wadood.
In the Quran, he calls himself Al-Wadood.
You know, Wastaqfiru Rabbakum summatubu ilaih inna Rabbir Rahimun Wadood.
Ask forgiveness of your Master and turn to Him in repentance.
Indeed, my Master is Rahim, He is the Most Merciful, Wadud, and He is most loving, His love is pure, because He is selfless in His love.
So Al-Wadud basically from a linguistic perspective, it has two meanings.
You know, it's both ways.
It's like .
Allah is the one who loves His servants, and He is the one who His servants love.
So it's a relationship of pure love both ways, right?
Allah has a pure selfless love for His creation, and then the creation has a pure selfless love for their master.
That's .
That's how they define Al-Wud.
It's a two-way street.
Al-Wadu fi'aibadihi wal Mawdood.
Right.
So, you know, so that's wood.
And interestingly, Allah is Wudud, and he describes the true purpose of a man and a woman coming together, you know, also in the same way, like,
There is ...
...
So there's Muwadda, right?
Amongst His signs is that He created for you wives from amongst yourself.
Why?
...
so that you may find Sukun, so that you may find repose in them.
And He has put between you pure love and mercy.
Right?
So, Allah says that He put mawadda between a man and woman, which is supposed to be at least pure love.
And like I said, pure love is a love that is pure from the inclinations of the self.
This is the type of love where the husband will not divorce his wife when she gets sick.
A husband will not divorce his wife when she's no longer beautiful.
You know, when she becomes fat.
So if you have mavadda for your wife, even after she gets fat, you'll still love her.
Seriously, if she gets sick, you'll still love her.
Because she'll still love you even when you get fat and ugly.
I mean, she'll still love you.
Because a woman's love is quite amazing that way.
A woman's love, it doesn't change the way a man's love changes.
Because that is not love that changes.
I love this poem of Shakespeare in which he says, Love is not love which alters when it alteration finds, or bends with the remover to remove.
Oh no, it is an ever fixed mark that looks on tempests and is never shaken.
That is real love.
That is Al-Wud.
And what Shakespeare meant by that is that love is not love that when things change or when the situation changes, your love changes.
You know, your wife is beautiful today so you love her but if she's no longer beautiful one day, it doesn't change your love.
If it does, then that was not love, that was just lust, right?
I know this woman who got into this accident where the side of her face got burnt off pretty bad, you know, on one side.
And the husband just divorced her just because she didn't look beautiful anymore.
So he just divorced her and sent her back to her parents.
I mean, that's not love.
That is sick, right?
But that is the state of some people.
But that is not real love.
If you think you're in love with someone, the best way for you to find out if you really love them, is just ask yourself this question.
If she gets burned today, if that beautiful face gets burned today, if she loses her beautiful voice, would you still love that person?
And if you cannot answer that question, then
you really are not in love.
You're just hormonal.
That's what it is.
Because women, if you look at women, they have a much deeper capacity for love than most men do.
I mean that's just a fact, right?
If that same accident happened to this guy where his face got burnt off, she would have still spent the rest of her life with him.
She would have taken care of him, she would have loved him the same way.
Because that is real love.
And women have a much greater capacity to love in this way than men do, right?
And this is why our Prophet is so amazing.
You know, he said, I was made to love women.
That statement has nothing to do with lust.
I was made to love women.
And I was made to love perfume and to love flossing.
What's the connection between women, perfume and flossing?
Perfume just gives, right?
Perfume dissipates its own existence for others, for us.
When you put on perfume, it diffuses and it gives up its own existence to make you smell nice.
Right?
A floss goes into a filthy mouth and it cleans it at the expense of ruining its own existence.
It sacrifices itself to clean our mouths What does the floss get out of that experience?
Nothing What does the perfume get out of that when we apply it?
Nothing That is the quality of women that our Prophet loved It was that sacrifice he loved that came so natural to a woman and men find it so difficult
You know, and this is why, you know, we learn love from our mothers, right?
You know, Rasulullah said, Paradise is under the feet of mothers, under the feet of mothers.
Because that's where we learn it best, right?
In our mothers, that love is where we see it most embodied.
and this is why in in Haditha Qudsi you know Allah speaks to Rasulullah and he says that I have derived you know I have derived the womb you know literally means to split like you know separate it split it out of something
He says, I have split the womb from My name of Ar-Rahman, the Merciful.
That is unique to women.
Men don't have wombs.
Right?
Allah gave that only to women.
And that womb is such a beautiful, is that space in the center of a woman that is the source of all mercy in this world.
I mean, that was our first abode, all of us.
We were all initially there in that abode of Rahma, of mercy.
And what's amazing is that, you know, that womb, it grows, it grows big to facilitate what's in it.
That is Rahma, that is mercy.
It is that emotion that grows with the need of the beloved.
Right?
That it expands itself to satisfy the need of others.
That's what mercy is.
That's what love is.
And this is why our Prophet sallallahu alaihi wa sallam, he's Rahmatul lil alameen.
We have not sent you but as a mercy to all of humanity.
Because that is what he did.
He was that womb.
He expanded for the needs of others.
That is wood.
Pure love.
Selfless love.
It is not that, you know, this utilitarian kind of love that, you know, a love that is tainted by one's own selfish needs.
It's not the type of love that we know of.
I'm going to get something out of this.
What's in it for me?
Wood is a love that transcends all of that.
It's the kind of love that when there is beauty, that love is there.
But then when the beauty goes away, the love is still there.
If the service is no longer there because
of a stroke or because of some incapacity, the love is still there.
That is real love.
You know, it's not really love when there is just usefulness from me, you know.
That's not love, that's just something else.
And you know, we are a society, we have no Muwadda, we have no Raham between ourselves.
Look at what we have become today, right?
We are a society, we are a community that is completely...
Forget Ummah as a Muslim, just us as a community.
I mean, there's no Rahma, there is no wood.
You know, we are void of this kind of love.
Everything, everything in our lives, in our relationships, you know, what's in it for me?
You know, why should I help you?
Why should I go out of my way?
You know, after that
that battle of Sifin, you know, when that battle of Sifin was over, this water man, you know, he narrates that he was on the battlefield searching for dying soldiers.
In those days, it was, I mean, you must have seen this in movies, that, you know, they had this man whose only duty was to carry around this Mashkiza, this water container.
And his only job was to quench the thirst of these dying soldiers because, you know, they're wounded and they say that right at the moment of death, one becomes extremely thirsty.
And so water helps with the transition.
So anyway, this man, he narrates that he was after the Battle of Syphine was over, he was carrying around this water on the battleground, searching for thirsty soldiers who are about to die.
and he came upon this one soldier this man whose lower part of his body it had been severed from you know his body so just basically his torso was sitting on the scorching ground and he was signed for water right Al-Atash Al-Atash he was just constantly saying you know water I'm thirsty I'm thirsty so and they say that that's an extreme form of thirst and so this man he says that he you know I walked up to him
And this guy, he brought the water, that cup, he poured the water in a cup and he brought the cup of water close to his lips of this dying man.
And they heard the cry of another man close by saying the same thing, .
So he says that this dying man, right, in that state, torso half cut up, he sealed his lips.
And he refused to drink that cup of water.
only so that I could quench the thirst of his brother first.
He says, I rushed towards this other man so that I could give him water and as I brought the cup close to his lips, they again heard another man sighing and this man sealed his lips so that I could first go and quench the thirst of this other person.
so he said I rushed to this third person to give him water but by the time I got there he had already died so then I returned to the second person and he had died and I returned to the first one and he had died by I mean this was love this was wood right that these people had for each other and where is that love today and how do we compare to these how do we
How do we measure up to these people?
I mean what were these people made of?
But that is you know this is the standard these people have set for us I mean our love is just you know just this Bollywood nonsense of chasing a girl around a tree singing a song I mean that's what you know we've reduced love to just
Fifth stage was what?
The next stage is what they call Shaqaf.
So, this is the stage of Shaqaf al-Qalb, which is basically the representation is the pericardium.
It's the stage where the heart is just surrounded by this love.
It encompasses the heart.
This is the state of...
It's just, I don't know how to describe this.
It's a state of obsession, but it's a state of pure, like there is no self, there's no nuffs involved.
It's like constantly thinking about the beloved.
Right?
You know, wherever you are, whatever you see, it just reminds you of the beloved.
It's that stage where you see the beloved everywhere, sunrise, sunset, everything beautiful, everything amazing reminds you of your beloved, the flower, the rose, the birds, the music, everything.
It just reminds you of the beloved and it's a very...
it's a very pure remember these are all incremental stages right so a person who is at the level of Sha'af he has already crossed the stage of wood so his love has become extremely pure now it's just that he's constantly engulfed by the beauty and and it's not for his own self it's just you know in love with the person itself that the beloved itself
Then comes the next stage is, after Shahaf, the next stage is Al Ishq.
Al Ishq.
This is a very dangerous state of love.
You know, people who go in this state of love, like for someone or for God, they end up going insane.
This is an insane love.
That's the only way to describe it.
And it's a very dangerous phase.
It's where they literally, like a person who is at the level of Ishf will appear insane to me.
It's like, are you insane?
Who does that?
It's that kind of love.
This stage of Ishf is where the lover enjoys pain and suffering for the sake of the beloved.
It's that state of intense love.
Right?
It's that state of insane love, I should say.
Somebody's mic is on.
Right?
So that's Al-Aish.
It's very interesting.
The word Aish, it comes from a vine called Ashaka, right?
And this vine
you know when it surrounds a tree it wraps itself around the tree it basically sucks out the life of that tree and eventually kills it that's where they get this term ishq because it's from ashaka it's that vine that wraps itself around the tree and sucks the life out of it and imamate in that is that the tree it sacrifices itself to nourish and feed this vine you know it kills itself
so that his beloved can survive that is Ishq but Ishq is this type of love where there is total constriction and the lover actually begins to suffer in the love of that beloved and enjoys that suffering that is Ishq and the Arabs say there is no cure to Ishq except that
The only cure for this insane love is meeting the beloved.
That's the only cure.
And people have, you know Firaun, during the time of Firaun, there was this woman who had turned Muslim, but she did not disclose her Islam to anyone.
And Firaun eventually found out and he summoned this woman to his court.
And so she was arrested and she was brought to court along with her two daughters.
And the older one was about 10 years old and the younger one was only a few months old.
And Surahan said to this woman, I have heard that you have turned Muslim.
You now believe in the God of Moses.
So I give you two choices.
The first choice is that you reject the God of Musa and you accept Me as your God.
If you do that, I will grant you and your daughters a palace in which you and your daughters will reside as royalty.
You will have all the comforts of this world.
Anything that you can imagine, you will have for the rest of your life, for the rest of your generations.
All you have to do is reject this God of Musa and accept me as God.
And the second choice is that if you reject my offer,
I will burn both your daughters alive in front of you and I will burn you alive as well.
And so this woman who was
at the stage of Ishq she rejected his offer so Firaon ordered his men to fill this large cauldron with oil right and it was heated till it started boiling before her eyes and Firaon asked her again do you accept my offer and she said I am already in love with Musa's God
How can I leave the one I love for you?
How can I reject him for you?
This is Ishq.
So by Firaun's command, his soldiers, they dragged her 10 year old and threw her in the boiling oil, right in front of her eyes.
I mean there are mothers in this group, you know, only a mother can understand what falls on her heart when
She sees her child burned to death in front of her.
But this woman, she saw that entire thing, she did not say a word.
Firaan asked her again, do you accept my offer now?
And she again refused.
So they snatched that few month old daughter from her arms and threw her in the boiling oil.
And she still did not say a word.
And they say that, you know, Rasulullah has narrated this and he says, right then,
the veils of the sky were removed before her eyes and she saw both her daughters in paradise saying to her you know mother just be patient a little while longer we're all soon going to be united in heaven and then came this woman's turn and so Firaun she turned to Firaun and she said you know I have one last request that after you killed me
Bury my bones and the bones of my daughters together in one place.
And Firaun said, Your wish will be granted.
And so they finally threw this woman in the burning oil as well, and she was united with her children.
And her last wish was fulfilled, and their bones were buried together.
2000 years later, there's about distance of 2000 years between Rasulullah and Musa.
And Rasulullah 2000 years later is being taken on Miraj,
And when Buraq flies over Baik al-Muqtis, the Prophet smells this fragrance of paradise.
And he asks Jibril, where is this fragrance coming from?
And Jibril narrated this entire incident to the Prophet.
And he said, since the day the bones of that woman and daughter were buried, this fragrance has been rising from their graves.
and all the angels rejoice and enjoy this fragrance.
I mean we don't possess the sense to smell that kind of fragrance but you know this was our Prophet SAW who sensed that fragrance because he was an angel in human form and so he asked that question but the point is this is the kind of suffering that the kind of sacrifice right
I mean, this is the story of Ishq of how this woman loved Allah and how Allah loved her back.
I mean, 2000 years later, the messenger sallallahu alaihi wasallam is sensing the fragrance of paradise rising up from their graves.
Subhanallah.
Right?
Karbala, the story of Karbala.
That's the Karbala is the story of Ishq.
That is the most amazing story of Ishq.
And Imam Hussain, you know, he's the leader, but every single person in that story, you know, every mahram we listen to these tales of Ishq.
And Karbala is a tale of insane love.
That's what Karbala is.
And you must have heard that story of that woman, right, in Imam Hussain's camp, where, you know, whose son goes to battle and returns back to her.
comes back and is completely covered in blood and wounds and he comes back and he calls out to his mother and he asks her and he says mother are you pleased with me now what mother could bear watching her son covered in wounds from head to toe and covered in blood and bleeding from you know everywhere
one mother could watch that but this woman she tells her you know and he's asking her are you pleased with me and she says no not yet she says not yet my son I will not be pleased with you until you sacrifice yourself for Imam Ghusain this is Isht and he goes back into battle and he fights till he's martyred and they cut off his head and they toss it towards the camp
and his mother comes out she takes his head in her puts it in her lap and she begins kissing his forehead and then she gives out this cream and dies but you know that is Ishq so Ishq is a very very dangerous stage of love and this is where there is just no extreme that the lover will not go to I mean there's just no limit here when it comes to Ishq
We just throw around this word, right, Mujhe Ishqo Gaya, but people don't really understand the depth of Ishq and what Ishq means.
Then the next phase is what they call Tatayyum, right?
The Taym is a word used for a slave, but it's still not at the level of Abd, right?
But it's a higher degree of love where
There is a type of servitude that goes with it.
This is where you are now in the service of beloved.
You're constantly in the service of the beloved.
The love reaches the stage of what can I do for you?
How can I serve you?
How can I make you happy?
That's all that matters to the team.
Pleasure comes from servitude.
How do I make the beloved happy?
What can I do for you?
Just saying I love you is not enough.
Tell me what I can do for you.
I want to do something.
That need of doing something for the beloved, anything, just to make the beloved happy, that's Sataya.
And the next stage after that is Taabud.
This is the stage where the lover becomes a complete slave of the beloved.
At this stage, at the stage of Aad, there is complete obedience in addition to servitude, right?
In the previous one there was just servitude, here there is complete obedience.
This is basically where the, you know, when the beloved says jump, the lovers, you know, asks how high, that's Taabud.
There is, it is a stage of unquestioned obedience of the beloved.
Right.
You know...
A poet says...
You claim to love your God and yet you disobey Him?
This kind of love just does not make any sense to my imagination.
Right?
So, Abd is the stage of complete obedience in love.
And this is the honorific title of our Messenger , that Allah called him Abd.
This is the greatest honor that was bestowed upon the Prophet.
You know, SubhanAllah .
Glorious is the one who took his slave for a journey in the night.
Not SubhanAllah the Asrah bir Rasoolihi Laylan, bin Nabihi Laylan, bihabibihi Laylan, no.
SubhanAllah the Asrah bia Abdihi Laylan.
Not messenger, not prophet, not beloved, nothing, just Abd.
Glorious is the one who took his Abd on the night journey.
This is the title of the Prophet.
He is, his title of Aab is greater than his title of Rasul, because of his Rabbudiya.
Right, so this is the level of Ta'abbud, which is, Ta'abbud is adoration basically, right?
You know, Aabid is the one who adores.
It's adoration, it's adore, it's from that Latin word adore.
So, Ubudia is where you move into the realm of adoration, where there is complete stillness and unconditional obedience of the Beloved.
The next stage after that is what they call Khullah, and this is the level of the Khaleel.
The Prophet said, Allah took me as a Khaleel,
Just as he took Ibrahim as a Khalil.
Right?
And this is the highest level of love.
You know, it's an extreme, it's that, you know, like what they say about the state of Khalil is
That's how they describe it.
Where the love completely permeates every cell of the body.
That is Takhlil.
No, Takhlil is where, when you penetrate deeply, like, you know when you do Takhlil as-Sha'a in the Ahkam of Ghusl, when we do Ghusl, you have to get to every hair follicle, that's Khullah, and it's a very high degree of love where
you know, the love has permeated the entire soul, every cell of the body is in love with the beloved.
I mean, how do you explain that?
It's just something that just transcends words.
You cannot really describe Khaleel, but that's what it is.
It's like, you know, you love the beloved with every cell, every pore of your body.
That's Khullah.
and the final stage of love is Muhabba there's really no word in the English language that I you know that can encompass the depth of this love I mean the word Muhabba it comes from the root word Hubba actually Habba which means seed
Right?
And this, it's never, the idea of Habba is that it's never ending, it's eternal kind of love.
It will never end.
You know, what happens when you sow a seed?
You get a harvest.
Right?
You get an exponential amount of return on your investment.
And what happens after you harvest the crop?
It grows back again.
You harvest again, grows back again.
That's hope.
That's eternal love.
And that is the Ma'am of the Prophet.
He is Habibullah.
He is the one that Allah loves in that way, eternally.
You know, can you just take a moment to appreciate the station of our Prophet?
I mean, Adam is Tafirullah, you know, the one Allah sent.
Noof is Najeeullah, the one Allah saved.
Musa is Kalimullah.
Ibrahim is Khalilullah, the one Allah befriended.
Musa is Kalimullah, the one Allah conversed with.
Isa is Roohallah, the one Allah breath His spirit into.
But Rasulullah , He is Habibullah.
He is the one Allah loved.
And this is extremely astonishing if you think about it.
We just say that Allah loves him, but just think about who is loving who.
I mean, what a personality that the Creator is in love with his created thing.
I mean, what does that say about our Prophet?
Where the Creator falls in love with him.
SubhanAllah.
Where, you know, the...
The entire creation is worried about pleasing Allah.
We are all worried about praising Allah, and Allah is worried about praising Rasulullah.
And indeed, your Master will give you so much that it will please you.
You will be well pleased.
You are the one I want to please.
Allah is promising His Messenger that He will give him and keep giving him so much until he is well pleased.
I mean, that is the kind of love, you know, Allah has for His Messenger.
And that's the kind of love that the Messenger had for Allah.
This is why to love the Messenger of Allah is to love Allah.
And to love Allah is to love the Messenger of Allah.
Right?
Say if you love Allah then follow me, Allah will love you.
I mean may Allah give us the Makaam of Muhabbah and may He increase us all in Muhabbah and make us people of Muhabbah.
You know the Prophet said, you know ...
You will not enter paradise until you believe and you will not believe until you love one another, until you spend on one another, until you take care of one another, right?
You will not achieve any good until you spend from that of what you love.
I mean how much do we spend in the way of Allah?
Because you know those who love, you know
You know, those who believe and they love Allah, they love Allah more than their dunya.
Those who claim to believe and love Allah, they love Allah more than their dunya.
Those who believe, they love Allah more than they love their dunya.
And we should think about what people are out there doing for their dunya, because it's amazing.
Look at how much people love their dunya.
Look what they are doing to possess their beloved.
Look how they are running after their beloved.
We really have to ask ourselves if we are doing one tenth for our akhirah as what they are doing for their dunya.
Just one tenth.
They're working
12 hours a day, 7 days a week, you know, amassing all of this stuff.
People learn about, you know, they invest in learning about the most bizarre things because they can trust them, you know, they learn about it.
They'll spend all this time learning about the most ridiculously stupid stuff because they love what they're doing.
We don't learn out of it to understand our Creator's book.
I mean, look at that.
Have you guys seen that advertisement about this guy, this advertisement for learning Italian?
I mean, they show this farm boy and he's in love with this Italian celebrity, right?
And so the idea is that she's going to be in his town for one evening, just one evening.
So he has this one shot, this one chance where he can meet her, right?
And if this is a TV advertisement, because they know they are talking to people
who understand that when you are in love, you will do anything for the beloved.
You'll do anything, right?
So this farm kid, he gets this Italian software to learn Italian in one night just so that he can speak with that celebrity visiting his town, right?
This is what love will do.
This is what a lover will do for his beloved.
That's a lover.
I mean, we are loveless people.
We just want to talk about love.
We don't want to do anything.
We don't want to make any effort in the name of love, right?
We don't learn Arabic, we don't take the time to...
This guy spends one night learning the entire language so that he could speak with his beloved.
We don't take the time to understand the language our beloved speaks to us in.
And how old are we?
We don't want to make the effort to understand the language in which Allah speaks to His creation.
We are lazy people.
We claim love, but none of it is true.
We are just fake lovers.
But there are lovers.
There are true lovers.
So if we are not in love, if we cannot be true lovers, we should at least
at the very least be in awe of these lovers like Rasulullah , Mawlana Ali, Imam Hussain, at least we should wish to be in love with them, right?
You know the Arabs they say that sometimes the ear falls in love before the eyes do.
You know you sometimes hear about someone and you just fall in love with them.
It's such
a beautiful thing I can't tell you how beautiful at some point I hope we all experience true love really I hope we all you know because Allah made this ishq this love in this world a sign an ayah to show us what divine love is he made ishq muhabba a sign in this world between people for us to understand what divine love is supposed to be like right it's a hujjah against us
Romeo and Juliet, that's a Hujja against us.
Laila and Majnun, that's a Hujja against us because if this is the love of a created thing for another created thing, then what kind of love should a creature have for his creator?
I mean if these are the depths, if these are the limits that you will go to in love for another human being,
Right?
What should be the depth of your effort for your Creator?
So this love is...
pure love is a beautiful thing.
I mean...
People long for love.
There are people who want it so bad.
they keep falling in love over and over again keep having their heart broken but they keep falling in love over just so so that for that experience of love and these are you know foolish people these are shock because like I said you know Ishq is a disease but then but then you know cure there is a cure it's meeting the beloved you know you will
You will want to meet your beloved so bad that you will go to the ends of the earth to meet this person, right?
Salman-e-Farsi, look at his love.
Look at his love.
Look what he did.
You know, this is a man who was sold in slavery unjustly, right?
And he was a slave.
He traveled all over just to find the messenger.
If he heard of any righteous man, right, he would go up to him, he would ask him, tell me about the Prophet, tell me what he looks like, tell me how he speaks.
I mean, his journey is an amazing journey to the Prophet .
I mean, how many of you even know the story, right?
I mean, this is the kind of lovers we are.
But you should really study his life, his journey to his Prophet, his sincerity.
you know Allah gave him the signs and he knew what to look for because of his sincerity so the first time he met the Prophet he brought him dates and he said this is Sadaqah and then he watched the Prophet not eat from it because he knew right he was told that the Prophet will not eat from charity and then the next time he came he brought him some dates and he said this is Hadiya it is gift and then the Prophet ate from it and Salman knew ah yeah just like I was told
And then he became Muslim.
And look at the love of the Prophet for Salman.
I mean look where love gets you.
Salman is from my family, he is part of our family.
Amazing, you know, these are lovers, amazing, amazing people of love.
you know when this when the Prophet came to Madina right and he let the reins of his camel go because everybody everyone wanted the Prophet to stay with them so you know and the Prophet was an extremely diplomatic person he did not want to upset anyone he did not want to offend anyone so what he said is that you know what here's what I'll do I'll leave the reins of my camel and I'll just let it walk and wherever she stops I will live with that person so the camel
he let go of the reins and the camel stopped in front of the house of Hazrat Abu Ayub Al Ansari and he rushed forward and he just lifted the bags of the Prophet and the Prophet said a man is with his luggage right so he took the Prophet in the house and he put him on the bottom floor because because you know he wanted to honor him you know somebody on the bottom floor is much
It's easier to live on the bottom floor than the top floor because you don't have to walk up the stairs, you can easily go outside, you have easy access.
So he wanted to give the Prophet the utmost ease.
So he housed him on the bottom floor.
And he and his wife, they took the floor above, but then he became extremely constricted.
He couldn't walk on the floor.
Because I don't want to put my foot
where the Prophet might have rested his head I mean this is adab we don't have I mean look at that adab we don't have any adab anymore so he went and he begged the Prophet you know ya Rasulullah we can't stay above you it's just and so the Prophet changed places with him right so his wife would take food upstairs for the Prophet
and after he ate when his wife brought the food back he would ask her show me show me where the messengers fingers ate from and then he would eat from that place right so this is tatabu al-asar right following the traces this was love amazing the kind of love these people have for the messenger amazing
Maimuna right his wife the Prophet's wife 30 years later after she married the Prophet right when she was nearing death you know where she wanted to go to the place where she spent the first night with the Prophet that is where she's buried I mean just look at that love look at that love amazing today we just
We just want to take love out of Islam and we want to make it into something ugly, I mean?
This religion is nothing if it's not about love.
This religion is nothing if it's not love.
No one is a believer until he loves his brother.
You know, he did not use any other word.
Ten stages of love and he uses the last stage, you know, .
That's the only word you use, love, until you love.
Say, if you love Allah, then follow me, and God will love you.
Because the sign of love is that you follow the beloved.
You do what the beloved says.
I mean, our religion, our history, our story, our legacy is a legacy of love.
I mean, we have such amazing lovers in our history.
I mean, look at this man's love.
I mean, when he heard the Prophet, you know, the Prophet's tooth got struck in the battle of Uhad,
He went insane.
You know, what did my messenger feel?
How much pain did my messenger feel when they struck?
Just to experience that same pain, he pulled out his own tooth.
Just to experience what his beloved experienced.
But then that was not enough, you know.
What if it was not this tooth?
What if it was this tooth?
So he pulled out another.
what if it was this one and he pulled out another you know what if it was this one he pulled out his entire he pulled out all of his feet this is love this is insane love this is I mean where do we stand I mean I ask myself that question I mean where do I stand it's just how do you compare to these lovers right
And this is why I feel that if we cannot love Allah, we should at least try to love the ones who Allah loved, at least the ones who loved Allah.
And if we cannot love them, we should love the ones who love those that loved Allah.
And love is a struggle.
When you love, you struggle, you sacrifice.
That's the nature of love.
You sacrifice for the one you love.
If you're not sacrificing, that's not love.
You know, that's not real love and it's just, you know, me, me, me, me.
People go to extremes, you know, we, you know, we go to...
Amaru bid diyari, diyari laila.
Aqbalulam jidaru walal jidara.
the poet says you know didn't you ask me about that place about that place that's no longer there didn't you ask me about that place where Laila used to live and then he said yeah indeed I did ask but how do dead stones give me answers you know where did everybody go and then he says
You know, I go by the stones, I go by the dwelling places of my beloved.
This is Majnun, right?
He says, I go by these stones, the dwelling places where Laila lived, and I kiss this wall, and I kiss that wall.
And he says, you know, It's not the love of the walls that has enraptured my heart, you know, but the love of the one who used to live in these walls.
This is why we go to these places This is why we go to Ziyara It's not places It's the Beloved He was there This is why we go there Because He walked there He slept there He ate there He prayed there That's why we go there Our religion is a religion of love
and everything we do in our religion it has to be out of love I swear everything it should be out of love I mean I'm talking about the most idealistic situation and I realize that you know but it's good to know these things right it's at least good to know what the goal is but everything in our religion is supposed to be out of love not out of fear we make religion out of fear that's so sad what we look what we've turned Islam into
Look how religion is portrayed to us, how we portray our religion to others.
I mean, we should do everything in our religion out of love, not fear.
Allah is worthy of fear, but even that fear of Allah, it should be rooted in love, right?
It's like the fear that a child has been upsetting or disappointing the parent, right?
Even though the child is afraid, but that fear is rooted in love.
They love the parents so much that they are afraid of upsetting them.
That should be our fear of Allah.
Should be rooted in love.
And Allah is, you know, Allah of Aqba, He is greater than anything that can be said about Him.
We can't praise you as the Prophet said We cannot praise you You are as you praised yourself so anything I say about Allah will be deficient and you know we need to we need to think about our lives we all need to think about our life this is our time you know
This is our time and what we do with this time is going to determine what happens when we leave this time.
Because we're all going to depart from this world.
So it is really important that I ask myself, you ask yourself, we all ask, how are we spending our time?
What are we doing with our time?
Are we doing useful, worthwhile things, beneficial things?
Are we getting closer to Allah?
Are we coming any closer to knowing our Prophet any better?
Because He is worth knowing.
I swear wallahi, He is worth knowing.
He is worth knowing beyond, above and beyond anything else that exists in this world.
He is worth knowing.
He is worth studying.
The stories about Him are worth knowing.
His ahadith, His family, His character, His etiquettes,
They're all worth knowing.
His family members are worth knowing.
Those who loved him are worth knowing.
You know, who are there and what they went through and that gives us sort of a compass, a direction of where we need to head.
So, you know, may Allah guide us all.
May He open up our hearts and put us all on this path of love.
Wahhardawan an alhamdulillahi Rabbil Alameen was salat, was salam ala rasuli Saila Muhammad al-Hatim al-Hatim al-Haatim